hier wird jetzt das thema gewechselt es
geht um das ressort bildung und
forschung forschung das geführt wird
sagt lisa oder in dieser
legislaturperiode von bettina stark
watzinger diplomierte volkswirt denn mit
dem wissenschaftssystem durchaus
vertraut 2017 ist jetzt erst mal in den
bundestag gekommen und vier jahre später
nun bundesministerin für bildung und
forschung 20 milliarden euro hätte sie
wahrscheinlich ungefähr die
haushaltsberatungen haben ja noch nicht
stattgefunden zur verfügung und die will
sie sinnvoll einsetzen denn so sagt
bettina stark watzinger wir bleiben in
deutschland das die bildung angeht unter
unseren möglichkeiten so oft bestimmen
die herkunft den bildungserfolg und
deswegen will sie da einiges dran tun
auch durchaus im eigenen sinne denn auch
die neue ministerin stammt aus einer
frankfurter handwerkerfamilie und hat
das der bildungsreform aus den späten
60er frühen 70er jahren zu verdanken
die kleinen momente im leben die das
große potenzial das unser land hat zeigt
eine junge frau sagt auf einer
abschlussveranstaltung eines
ausbildungsprogramms beschrieb sich was
die unter elite versteht das ist nicht
nur ja das ist kein luxus sie sagte lied
ist jeden tag aufzustehen sich
anzustrengen über die eigenen grenzen
hinaus zu gehen und etwas besser machen
in diesem land es sind könig menschen
die unser land voranbringen
selbst bestimmt aber diese
selbstbestimmung die ist uns nicht in
die wiege gelegt diese selbstbestimmung
bekommt man nur durch bildung
deshalb kann es uns nicht ruhen lassen
das in unserem reichen land noch jeder
fünfte jugendliche nicht ausreichend
lesen kann dass es auch mehrere
generationen braucht bis man aus der
sogenannten einfachen in die
mittelschicht aufsteigt meine damen und
herren wo die jugenden jungen menschen
herkommen das können sie sich nicht
aussuchen aber wo sie hingehen das
sollen sie selbst bestimmen können und
das ist unser
hauptziel
vielmehr als individuelle karrierewege
denn das wissen jedes einzelnen ist die
grundlage für das wissen von uns ein für
das zukünftige wissen und bildung und
forschung sie sind treiber für wohlstand
sie haben eine immense
gesamtgesellschaftliche bedeutung
deutschland ist innovationsland und
deutschland soll und muss
innovationsland leyen meine damen und
herren mit der besten und modernsten
bildung wollen wir leben chancen
schaffen in der regierung mit bester
forschung und lösungen für die
herausforderungen
nicht mit den antworten der
vergangenheit sondern mit den neuen
technologien der zukunft suchen das
steht im programm das gehen wir
was
sagen sie uns vorgenommen die panini hat
uns schmerzlich gezeigt wie wichtig
bildung ist und derzeit müssen wir alles
tun um präsenzunterricht zu ermöglichen
damit das recht auf bildung verwirklicht
wird schulen sie gehören zur kritischen
infrastruktur
und teils test kapazitäten knapp werden
dann dürfen schülerinnen und schüler
nicht das nachsehen haben in unserem
land deshalb muss die schule mindestens
den rand an kultureinrichtungen bekommen
in der kritischen infrastruktur
digital pack 2.0 wollen wir die nächste
stufe der digitalisierung schaffen die
digitale revolution sieht passiert geben
wir unseren kindern und jugendlichen den
passt in die zukunft den sie brauchen
ihn darf werden
konnte
nicht nur die nach nehmen aber die sehen
doch dass schülerinnen gezielt und
unterstützung brauchen und deswegen
unser programm startchancen damit werden
wir 4000 schulen in sozial schwierigen
lagen besonders unterstützen mit
investitionsprogramm und chancen budget
meine damen und herren drittens
das bekommt ein neues dach
wird wir wollen es flexibler wir wollen
es attraktiver und moderner machen und
vor allem auch eltern unabhängiger
bildung darf nicht an fehlenden chancen
scheitern eine damen und eine
hexe
initiative für berufliche bildung wird
ihre bedeutung muss ich ihm ansehen dass
wir hier entgegen bringen wollen in
unserer gesellschaft dann auch wieder
finden und wir wissen das programm der
koalition es ist ambitioniert wir wollen
nicht nur reparieren sondern wir wollen
vor die welle kommen und dazu braucht es
alle kommunen länder und den bund
gemeinsam können wir die kehrtwende
schaffen nicht mit einem verbot der
zusammenarbeit nur mit einem gebot der
bund steht
die kann zeigt das exzellente forschung
vermag schon jetzt können wir uns mit
den m rna impfstoffen gegen das corona
virus impfen lassen in zukunft
hoffentlich auch gegen krebs wir
brauchen durchbrüche große sprünge echte
innovation wir wollen freie exzellente
forschung ermöglichen und zugleich in
missionen entwickeln missionen das heißt
auf kooperation setzen sozial und
technologische innovation verbinden
brücken zwischen disziplin bauen ein
beispiel mit blick auf den klimaschutz
mit wasserstoff entstehen aus abgasen
der stahlwerke vorprodukte für
kraftstoffe kunststoffe und dünger
gelingt es uns nur ein stahlwerk auf
wasserstoff umzustellen können wir damit
so viel co2 einsparen die eine ganze
großstadt verursacht das muss unser ziel
sein statt kleiner schritte des
verzichts große schritte des
fortschritts
2 letztlich meine zeit ist begrenzt
entscheidender erfolg ist dass das
wissen aus der forschung in der praxis
ankommt deswegen die enterprise tools
die wir schaffen wollen deswegen da die
deutsche agentur für transfer und
innovation eine art partnervermittlung
für wissenschaft wirtschaft und
zivilgesellschaft
wir müssen die potenziale unserer talent
aber unserer daten nutzen deshalb wollen
wir möglichst viel frischen möglichst
umfassenden zugriff auf forschungsdaten
ermöglichten eine zeitung schrieb
neulich neue daten können alte meinungen
ändern lassen wir diese chance nicht
verziehen es ist unsere aufgabe als
erfinder nation neue technologien zu
fördern die beste bildung für die frei
entwickeln zu geben wir wollen echten
fortschritt das ist das ziel dieser
koalition ich freue mich da auch vielen
dank meine dame
mit mehr stationär mit der vorstellung
ihrer pläne ihrer vorhaben in den
nächsten jahren in dieser ampelkoalition
bildung und forschung sind ihr ein
anliegen und es gibt da durchaus einiges
zu tun wie wir eben auch von ihr gehört
haben erste rednerin dazu wird nadine
schön sein aus der unionsfraktion und
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
frau ministerin stark watzinger
herzliche glückwünsche zu ihrem neuen
amt
für die unions fraktion wünsche ich
ihnen alles gute viel freude bei der
arbeit und natürlich auch viel erfolg
denn das thema bildung forschung und
entwicklung liegt auch uns wirklich sehr
am herzen auch wir wollen dass wir in
unserem land an der stätte vorankommen
und wenn sie sagen sie wollen dass
deutschland weiter innovationsland ist
und bleibt dann haben sie uns an ihrer
seite
sie finden bei uns eine ausgestreckte
hand vor allem dann wenn es um die vier
m geht um mehr mittel um neue methoden
um mehr mut und auch wenn es um die
menschen geht und
ich fange anwalt den mitteln sie haben
eben ihre räte mit dem thema forschung
und entwicklung der ntc sagen den
koalitionsvertrag wir wollen 2,5 prozent
des bruttoinlandsprodukts für forschung
und entwicklung ausgeben
wir sind in den letzten jahren für
dieses ziel den größten teil des weges
gegangen und wir finden es gut dass sie
den westen gehen wir sind mittlerweile
bei etwa 2,2 prozent angelangt und es
ist schon wahnsinn was wir gemeinsam
geschafft haben wenn man sich die
entwicklung anschaut 2005 als kanzlerin
merkel bundeskanzlerin wurde hatten wir
beim bmwf einen etat von 7,6 milliarden
und im letzten jahr lag der bei 20
milliarden euro das heißt der etat des
bmbf hat sich mehr als verdoppelt
150 prozent auf vox wir sind bei fast 22
prozent
und wir wünschen ihnen viel erfolg für
die letzten bis 0,4 prozent und
unterstützen das wenn sie das schaffen
und wir haben nicht nur mehr geld
investiert wir haben vor allem auch
diese entwicklung immer wieder angepasst
das thema wasserstoff haben sie erwähnt
anja karliczek als minister den hat hier
den schwerpunkt gelegt mit unterstützung
unserer bundestagsfraktion und wir
setzen auf diese zukunftstechnologien
und freuen uns wenn sie diesen weg
weitergehen das gilt auch etwa für das
thema gesundheitsforschung für die
hightech strategie für die
batterieforschung das sind die richtigen
grundlagen in dieser legislaturperiode
gelegt worden wir haben den pakt für
forschung und innovation geschaffen
fantastische mittel bis 20.30 darauf
dafür werden wir weltweit bereitet und
auch hier eine gute grundlage auf die
sie aufbauen können wo sie weitermachen
können wir unterstützen ist wenn sie
mehr auf transfers setzen auch das haben
der getan der pakt für forschung und
innovation setzt zum ersten mal auf
transfer darauf dass aus dem was
erforscht wird eben auch
geschäftsmodelle und produkte werden
deshalb freuen wir uns wenn sie auch
hier die arbeit fortsetzen
ich will aber an der stätte sagen
transfer zu fördern darf nicht
verwechselt werden mit nicht mehr in
grundlagenforschung zu investieren wir
brauchen eine gute grundlagenforschung
in unserem land denn nur
grundlagenforschung ermöglicht die
wirken wirklich großen sprünge das haben
wir etwa bei madonna in stoff gesehen
der deshalb so schnell entwickelt worden
ist weil eben auch grundlagenforschung
bis jetzt wurden ist das sehen wir beim
thema beauty industrie funkt 4.0 wo in
unserem land grundlagenforschung gemacht
worden ist die natürlich auch den
unternehmen hilft und die kurssprünge
der zukunft werden aus der
grundlagenforschung auch entstehen und
wir müssen es schaffen dass das was dort
entwickelt und gedacht wird dann auch
tatsächlich in produkte und
geschäftsmodelle kommt das heißt aber
nicht dass wir nur noch auf
anwendungsorientierte forschung dazu
müssen sondern wir brauchen
beides
frau ministerin es geht um mehr mittel
es geht aber auch um mehr mut und ich
kann ihnen sagen was wir in den letzten
jahren oft mit dem koalitionspartner
gekämpft haben wenn es darum ging wie
regulieren wir den innovations- offen
etwa beim thema künstliche intelligenz
etwa beim thema daten und es klingt
überhaupt nicht nur mehr geld ins
schaufenster zu stellen sie müssen auf
den start ups dem vorstand den
unternehmen ermöglichen auch aus diesen
entwicklungen produkte und
geschäftsmodelle zu machen und jetzt
gerade bei der regulierung auf
europäischer ebene haben sie die
gelegenheit sich dafür einzusetzen dass
wir hier nach vorne kommen wir haben in
der vergangenheit hier oft nicht
einheitlich gesprochen weil das spd
geführte justizministerium uns an vielen
vielen stellen blockiert hat und deshalb
wünsche ich ihnen dass sie es schaffen
auch in europa und auch in unserem land
eine innovation zu erforschen
regulierung zu schaffen denn nur dann
können sie all das was sie jetzt
versprechen was wir uns auch wünschen
tatsächlich umsetzen viel erfolg bei
dieser aufgabe auch hier haben sie uns
an ihrer seite
die spieler den schön die staffel
neue methoden haben die grundlage gelegt
in dieser legislaturperiode vor allem
bei dem thema vor seit neue prozesse wie
wir auch entwicklungen ins politische
geschäft mit implementieren auch da
brauchen wir eine bessere verknüpfung
von wissenschaft wirtschaft verwaltung
und politik und da auch darauf setzen
wir hier werden wir sehr genau
beobachten ob sie diese entwicklung
weiter fordern greifen und der fürther
sind die menschen und mit den menschen
meine ich die vielen klugen köpfe in
unserem land die unser land voranbringen
wir setzen auf die jungen menschen denen
wir die beste bildung mit auf den weg
geben wollen wir setzen aber eben auch
auf die vielen die im strukturwandel
sich neu orientieren wollen und müssen
und deshalb setzen wir auf bildung und
auf weiterbildung das wird nicht allein
dadurch gelingen dass man 4000 schulen
in deutschland gut ausgestattet das eine
gemeinsame anstrengung von bund und
ländern mit dem digital schule haben wir
groß vorgelegt sechseinhalb millionen
euro die dafür
zur verfügung stehen und uns ging es
auch zu langsam ist kann nicht sein dass
zwei jahre nach der pandemie drei jahren
haft der digital packt geschaffen wurde
immer noch in vielen schulen die geräte
nicht angekommen sind das werden sie
aber nicht allein dadurch lösen dass sie
einen digital platz zwei machen dann
müssen sie mit den ländern sprechen da
müssen auch strukturen geändert werden
in der zusammenarbeit zwischen bund und
ländern und da müssen auch die länder
ihre hausaufgaben machen denn gute
bessere bildung gerade im digitalen
bereich schaffen wir nur wenn alle ihre
hausaufgaben machen mein heimatland das
saarland hat gestern angekündigt dass
wir eine qualitätsoffensive für alle
schulen machen dass wir das thema
informatik ab klasse 5 eine andere
schulen einführen dass wir auf mint
setzen in allen bereichen dass wir die
berufliche bildung stärken und nur dann
wird es gelingen wenn die länder ihre
hausaufgaben machen wenn wir als bund
auch mit anpacken aber strukturell nicht
allein durch 4000 deutschen schulen auch
hier haben sie uns an der seite wenn es
um eine gute ausbildung der jungen
menschen geht gerade was die
zukunftsthemen sind in digitale bildung
angeht in diesem sinne viel erfolg für
ihre arbeit bei den innovativen themen
haben sie uns an ihrer seite ich freue
mich auf die zusammenarbeit bei den
themen bildung forschung und entwicklung
und jetzt ist man ihn schon tatsächlich
fertig mit um entschuldigung für die für
den fehlstart eben kommt vor ja wir sind
in der debatte über den über das ressort
bildung und forschung das ganze hatte
ein bisschen was von einer
generaldebatte das merken sie schon denn
es liegen ja hier weder aus als pläne
vor über die zu diskutieren ist noch
gesetzentwürfe oder anträge und deswegen
macht hier jede rednerin jeder redner so
seine punkte die ihm wichtig sind im
hinblick auf dem nächsten vier jahre und
im hinblick auf dieses ressort und
genauso gibt es sagen mit oliver
kaczmarek spd-fraktion erreicht worden
ist seit die uns 1998 aufgemacht haben
den reformstau in deutschland aufzulösen
aber es dort trotzdem richtig dass wir
jetzt auch eine zeit anfangen müssen in
der tatsächlich neue wege gegangen
werden weil wir gemerkt haben in der
alten konstellation sind wir an
entscheidenden stellen für das
wissenschaftssystem für die
bildungspolitik nicht weitergekommen und
will dafür einige punkte nennen
bildung und forschung das ist verbunden
mit zwei zentralen versprechen an unsere
gesellschaft nämlich zum einen mit dem
versprechen dass jeder mensch die
gleichen chancen hat
aufstieg und teilhabe durch bildung in
unserer gesellschaft zu erwerben und
zwar unabhängig davon was seine eltern
oder ihre eltern besitzen unabhängig von
nationaler herkunft oder geschlecht und
dieses bildungs und teilhabe versprechen
ist tatsächlich strapaziert und das ist
uns durch die pandemie nach besonders
vorgeführt worden und besonders
fokussiert worden wir wissen wie
bedenklich sich die infektionszahlen
schulbetrieb entwickeln wir wissen aber
auch was passiert wenn kinder und
jugendliche den schülerinnen und
schülern nicht zur schule gehen können
was das für lern rückstände bedeutet was
aber insbesondere für das soziale
miteinander bedeutet und welche sozialen
und psychischen auffälligkeiten im
mittlerweile auch einen schulalltag
feststellen deswegen bin ich ihnen frau
ministerin stark watzinger sehr dankbar
dass sie das hier noch mal deutlich
gemacht haben wir müssen alles dafür tun
zu vermeiden dass es dauerhafte und
flächendeckende schulschließung noch
einmal klipp gibt das recht auf bildung
in der pandemie heißt so lange wie
möglich den schulbesuch ermöglichen und
da müssen wir alle gemeinsam daran
arbeiten diesen ländern
ich will aber auch sagen wir haben
mittlerweile das vierte semester an den
hochschulen in dem studierende mit
einschränkungen zu kämpfen haben und wir
wissen dass es besonders die hart trifft
die ohnehin nicht besonders gut mit geld
ausgestattet sind zu viele sind an
unseren hochschulen und zwar unabhängig
von der pandemie das hat die pandemie
aber noch mal deutlich gemacht und
deshalb das bafög grundlegend zu
reformieren das ist eine herausragende
aufgabe in dieser wahlperiode übrigens
auch ein punkt wo wir der letzten
koalition nicht mehr weitergekommen sind
und dass hier zu reformieren und richtig
tatkräftig anzupacken auch schnell
anzupacken ist eine unserer wichtigsten
aufgaben in dieser welt
wir wollen dass es mehr studierende
bekommen und zwar viel mehr studierende
als jetzt bekommen wir uns lebensnäher
gestalten eltern unabhängiger ja aber
auch schulden einmal gestalten wir
wollen das als ein wahrer gibt dass die
menschen vertrauen und das ist gerne
auch hilft beim abschluss eines studiums
das zweite
das zweite versprechen von bildung und
forschung ist doch und verehrten gerade
eine debatte über anderes ressort wo das
auch im mittelpunkt stand mit den
erkenntnissen der wissenschaft die
großen herausforderungen unserer zeit zu
lösen miteinander mit fortschritt mit
wissenschaft dafür zu sorgen dass
fortschritt und die hoffnung auf ein
besseres leben auch platz findet der
politik wir glauben und das zieht sich
durch diesen koalitionsvertrag die
voraussetzung ist wertschätzung für
wissenschaft zu machen und wertschätzung
für wissenschaft nicht nur abstrakt im
munde zu führen sondern konkret spürbar
zu entwickeln uns die zahl insbesondere
für die dem system forschen und lehren
und deswegen will ich drei punkte kurz
nennen wir glauben erstens forschungen
auf spitzenniveau und echte
wissenschaftsfreiheit auch echte
individuelle wissenschaftsfreiheit ist
nur von zu verwirklichen durch gute
arbeit in der wissenschaft
und wir werden dazu ein maßnahmenbündel
in die hand nehmen das wissenschafts
zeit vertrags gesetz außerdem punkte
noch aus der letzten wahlperiode übrig
geblieben in die hand nehmen reformieren
wir werden das thema check programm das
professorinnenprogramm
verstetigen und weiterführen wir werden
natürlich auch bei der aufgabe
dauerstellen für dauer- aufgaben zu
schaffen wo insbesondere die länder auch
in der verantwortung sind nicht
nachlassen insgesamt wollen wir dafür
sorgen dass eben nicht in der
wissenschaft verbreitet die sorge um den
lebensunterhalt und die vertragslaufzeit
den alltag prägt sondern die
konzentration auf forschung lehre durch
gute arbeit möglich ist
wir haben uns zweitens vorgenommen die
strecke zu verkürzen zwischen der
grundlagen erkenntnis bis zur anwendung
dazu wollen wir forschungsprogramme
ressortforschung hightech-strategie
fokussieren auf die zentralen
herausforderungen wir wollen vor allem
sind es gerade auch angesprochen frau
ministerin nach einem jahrzehnt der
diskussion dem kind nicht nur einen
namen geben mit der deutschen agentur
für transfer und innovation sondern uns
der großen herausforderung stellen mit
diesem instrument tatsächlich die
leistungsdimensionen transfer wirksam zu
fördern wovon vor allem die hochschulen
für angewandte wissenschaften die
technischen universitäten profitieren
werden die daten ist auch ein
meilenstein den wir uns vorgenommen
haben für diese wahlperiode und er wird
in der fläche sie zusammen helfen
innovationen zu fördern
wir wollen die hochschulen wieder ins
zentrum stellt den zukunftsvertrag für
forschung und lehre dynamisieren und
damit auch gleichberechtigt aufwachsen
lassen zudem forschungsausgaben aber ich
will zum schluss nur einmal sagen
aufstieg und teilhabe und fortschritt
durch forschung als die beiden zentralen
versprechen von bildungs- und
forschungspolitik dass sie die
herausforderung die wir ganz konkret
spürbar für die menschen im alltag
verbessern wollen und wir freuen uns das
gemeinsam mit der bundesregierung an pak
zu können erzählt
oliver kaczmarek für die spd fraktion in
der bildungs- und forschungspolitischer
sprecher ist zum ressort für bildung und
forschung nächste rednerin aus der
fdp-fraktion nicole höchst auch sie ist
bildungs und forschungspolitische
sprecherin
frau bundesbildungsministerin werte
kollegen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren frau ministerin in unser aller
interesse wünsche ich ihnen viel erfolg
bei ihrer neuen aufgabe
bildung ist in der tat für unser land
einen schlüsselbereich um den wohlstand
und die zukunftsfähigkeit deutschlands
und seine zukünftigen generationen zu
sichern
leider habe ich auch im zwanzigsten
bundestag wiederum den eindruck gewonnen
dass auch der neuen koalition
bildung nicht so wichtig ist daran
ändern auch ihre hochglanz reden nichts
zum einen entspricht der
koalitionsvertrag zum thema bindung
beinahe wortwörtlich dem der letzten
regierung frau ministerin ist es ihnen
nicht hochnotpeinlich die gleichen
leeren worthülsen und die gebrochenen
versprechen
der gleichen themen wieder zu verwenden
sie recyceln einfach die ideen die
deutschland bereits vor den crooner
maßnahmen in die bildungskatastrophe
führte immerhin und muss ich ihnen
ausdrücklich zustimmen haben sie in
ihren reden hier als bildungsministerin
betont dass ihr ziel die welt beste
bildung für alle sein
das fordern hier von der afg schon immer
ministerin
sie haben in ihrer rede zur
ganztagsschule durchaus treffend
formuliert ich zitiere mit erlaubnis des
präsidiums die bildung in unserem land
ist nicht auf dem niveau das wir uns
wünschen jeder fünfte jugendliche kann
nicht gut lesen schon in der grundschule
hapert es lernen die kinder dort
wirklich die grundkompetenzen in lesen
und schreiben nein sie sagt dass gerade
wieder meinen respekt für diese
aufrichtige zustandsbeschreibung der
bildungskatastrophe in unserem land
lassen sie sich das auf der zunge
zergehen meine damen und herren die
unsere bildungsministerin stellt
offiziell im deutschen bundestag fest
dass unser bildungssystem
gescheitert ist nur so kann man es
nämlich bezeichnet wenn derart viele
unserer kinder nicht einmal mehr richtig
lesen und schreiben lernen klappe zu
affe tot
verantwortlich ist ausschließlich die
politik ihrer parteien in bund und
ländern die seit jahrzehnten unser
vormals leistungsfähiges bildungssystem
ja man könnte schon fast sagen
planmäßig gegen die wand fährt sie haben
damit und ich spreche sie als politiker
und verantwortungsträger auch persönlich
an unseren kindern die zukunft gestohlen
jahr frau ministerin eine vollständige
umkehr in der bildungspolitik ist
dringend geboten nun setzen sie sich als
ministerin ihre haltung flexiblen truppe
bitte um was sie selbst letztes jahr
gefordert haben initiieren sie eine
ehrliche bestandsaufnahme der korona
bedingten psychischen und physischen
schäden der kinder durch die
schulschließung sie von der regierung
müssen die rechte unserer kinder endlich
ernst nehmen statt sie nur plakativ ins
grundgesetz schreiben zu holen sorgen
sie dafür dass
unseren kindern das recht auf bildung
nicht noch einmal vorenthalten wird und
geben sie eine staatliche garantie für
einen vollständigen präsenzunterricht
ihre forderung handeln sie danach sie
dürfen sich dazu inhaltlich gerne an
unseren zeitlos aktuellen anträgen zum
umgang mit corona an schulen ab dem
sommer 2020 bedienen und die satire
verkaufen das können sie von den nun
freien demokraten ja besonders gut
stellen sie sich schützend vor lehrer
und schüler beenden sie die angst solche
kinder sind keine pandemie treiber
verhindern sie eine impfpflicht an
schulen laut tagesspiegel meine damen
und herren von gestern nachmittag ist in
spanien die pandemie vorbei und soll
behandelt werden wie eine grippe trotz
hoher fallzahlen kern auf wir um zurück
in die zukunft sorgen sie für die
weltbeste bildung für alle darin haben
sie unsere vollste unterstützung vielen
dank
[Applaus]
zu ihrer ersten rede im 20ten deutschen
bundestag hat nun die kollegin nina star
aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
dass
der geehrte präsidentin sehr geehrte
ministerin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte damen und herren
ich freue mich sehr heute hier zum thema
bildungspolitik meine erste rede halten
zu dürfen denn das was wir alle wissen
dass der bildungserfolg von kindern nach
wie vor viel zu stark vom elternhaus
abhängt das habe ich hautnah erfahren in
fast 20 jahren arbeit mit kindern und
jugendlichen bei kindern deren eltern
ihnen nicht bei den schulaufgaben helfen
konnten bei kindern die in wohngruppen
gelebt haben weil ihre eltern mit dem
familienleben überfordert waren und als
lehrerin in einer schule in berlin
neukölln und was ich da immer wieder
erlebt habe das waren kinder und
jugendliche die so großartige talente
hatten aber die trotzdem von der
gesellschaft längst abgeschrieben waren
und das merken diese kinder und
jugendlichen und das nimmt ihnen die
chance auf eine gute zukunft und das
kann und das will ich so nicht hinnehmen
und es bin ich sehr froh dass wir als
ampelkoalition ganz klar sagen bildung
darf nicht vom elternhaus abhängen
kinder müssen alle die beste bildung und
damit die besten chancen auf ein
selbstbestimmtes leben haben
und die letzten zwei jahre im
ausnahmezustand im ausnahmezustand der
pandemie die haben die ungerechtigkeiten
zwischen kindern massiv verschärft
deshalb ist es höchste zeit dass wir
endlich die bedürfnisse von kindern
wieder in den mittelpunkt stellen
ich möchte explizit an dieser stelle
allen familien danken den eltern die
neben home office auch kinderbetreuung
und homeschooling geguckt haben den
lehre sind die alles getan haben um
diese zeit für ihre schüler in so gut
wie möglich zu gestalten aber vor allem
den kindern und jugendlichen die so
solidarisch waren und auch so vieles
verzichtet haben es ist zeit dass wir
ihn endlich was zurückgeben
und nicht nur ich bin froh dass wir das
als koalition tun werden nicht nur mit
blick auf die pandemie wofür uns ganz
klar ist dass kinder und jugendliche in
zukunft so wenig wie möglich
eingeschränkt werden müssen sondern auch
mit blick darauf dass endlich alle
kinder gute startchancen bekommen der
koalitionsvertrag ist getragen von der
gemeinsamen überzeugung dass nicht mehr
postleitzahl oder doch der eltern
sondern das eigene auto über den
bildungserfolg entscheiden sollen er ist
getragen von der überzeugung dass
gerechte bildungschancen nicht vom
himmel fallen sondern das ergebnis
politischen handelns sind und dass
aufstieg durch bildung keine phrase sein
darf sondern jeden tag aktiv ermöglicht
werden muss und dass dieses ermöglichen
unsere verantwortung hier ist und der
wende uns stellen
gemeinsam
gemeinsam wollen wir die weichen für ein
jahrzehnt des aufbruchs und der
erneuerung für den sozialen ökologischen
und digitalen fortschritts stellen
dieser aufbruch davon bin ich überzeugt
beginnt in den kitas schulen und
hochschulen
ich bin selbst mutter von drei kindern
und ich weiß wie gut wie wichtig gute
und zuverlässige betreuung ist darauf
müssen sich alle familien verlassen
können deshalb werden wir den
rechtsanspruch auf ganztagsbetreuung im
grundschulalter umsetzen und dabei die
qualität nach vorne stellen
schon vor dem jahreswechsel haben wir
dafür gesorgt dass kommunen das geld für
den ausbau auch im neuen jahr verwenden
können und damit für planungssicherheit
gesorgt klar ist aber auch kitas und
schulen sind in erster linie keine
betreuung sondern bildungseinrichtungen
und deshalb müssen sie vom kind aus
gedacht werden und den bedürfnissen von
kindern gerecht werden und dafür stehen
wir in dieser koalition
gerechte chancen in der schule das
bedeutet auch weg von der gießkanne und
gezielt dort unterstützen wo es wirklich
nötig ist mit dem programm startchancen
sorgen wir für bildungsgerechtigkeit da
wo sie am dringendsten gebraucht wird
mehr als 4000 schulen bauen wir zum
modernen klimagerechten barrierefreien
schulen mit einer zeitgemäßen näheren
umgebung aus wir schaffen freie chancen
budgets fordern schule entwicklungen
unterstützen bis zu 8000 schulen mit
zusätzlichen stellen für
schulsozialarbeit mit dieser gezielten
unterstützung können wir wirklich etwas
verändern
mit dem digital pack 2.0 werden wir
unsere schulen fit für das lernen in der
digitalen welt machen wir bauen die
bürokratie ab und sorgen dafür dass das
geld schnell und direkt an den schulen
ankommt klar ist dabei der neue digital
kg muss besser gestrickt war und weiter
bis an gestrickt sein und weitergedacht
werden neben technik wollen wir viel
stärker auch medienkompetenz investieren
und gemeinsam mit ländern beraten rund
um den digitalen unterricht vom kopf auf
die füße stellen und frau schön ich habe
ihn dazu gehört und freue mich wirklich
sehr dass sie da jetzt feststellen dass
alle ihre hausaufgaben machen werden und
wir als koalition wir machen uns jetzt
daran die liegengebliebenen hausaufgaben
von ihnen insbesondere im digitalen
bereich endlich umzusetzen
und als lehrerin weiß ich gute bildung
lebt von kooperationen sie braucht
tragfähige beziehungen ein respektvolles
miteinander und den mut konflikte offen
ehrlich und lösungsorientiert
auszutragen das geld im klassenzimmer
wie in der politik gemeinsam mit ländern
und kommunen wollen wir auch in der
bildungspolitik eine neue kultur der
zusammenarbeit begründen um die bildung
in unserem land nach vorne zu bringen
bedanken möchte ich mich an dieser
stelle insbesondere bei den kolleginnen
von spd und fdp für den guten start in
die neue legislatur und auch die
opposition möchte ich ein laden dass wir
nicht nur das trennende sondern das
gemeinsame und den austausch miteinander
suchen wenn nötig hart in der sache aber
fairen umgang zum wohl der kinder und
jugendlichen in diesem land
wir wünschen insbesondere ihnen frau
ministerin eine glückliche hand und
gutes gelingen wir freuen uns sehr auf
die gemeinsame arbeit für eine
chancengerechte bildung herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat die kollegin nicole gohlke
für die fraktion die
linke nicole gohlke ist stellvertretende
vorsitzende ihrer fraktion
kolleginnen und kollegen ein jahrzehnt
der bildungschancen das verspricht die
neue ampel regierung und das wäre auch
so was von überfällig nachdem wir der
verwirklichung der bildungsrepublik die
ja die letzte bundesregierung
versprochen hatte jetzt nicht besonders
nahe gekommen sind für die linke ist
klar die bloße verwaltung des mangels in
der bildung durch die politik muss
endlich ein ende haben
der neoliberalismus und die
unterfinanzierung das muss man so
aussprechen der neoliberalismus und die
unterfinanzierung der letzten jahrzehnte
haben das bildungssystem
heruntergewirtschaftet der putz fällt
von den decken überall fehlen fachkräfte
es fehlt ein digitaler ausstattung viele
beschäftigte im bildungssystem sind
dramatisch unterbezahlt und die wahrheit
ist dieses deutsche bildungssystem
verschärft die soziale spaltung in der
gesellschaft abgehängt bleiben in der
regel abgehängt dem viel beschworenen
bildungsaufstieg in gibt es quasi nicht
nur wer es sich leisten kann kommt mit
privaten bildungsangebote weiter nur wer
es sich leisten kann schafft es an die
uni und kann ins ausland gehen das ist
die situation und ich finde es geht hier
und heute genau darum um nichts
geringeres als darum diesen zustand
endlich zu beenden und zu verändern
und dafür kolleginnen und kollegen dafür
muss man neue wege beschreiten weg von
der spaltung in elite und den rest weg
von der privatisierung der
bildungsaufgaben weg von der
mangelwirtschaft aber genau das das
fehlt mir im koalitionsvertrag der ampel
es ist ja schön sag ich mal dass sie die
digitalisierung in den breitband ausbau
vorantreiben wollen aber das ist ja wohl
noch kein bildungspolitischer aufbruch
aus meiner sicht sind das
selbstverständlichkeiten worüber sie
aber kaum sprechen worüber sie kaum
sprechen sind strukturelle veränderungen
im bildungssystem die man angehen müsste
kein wort verlieren sie dazu wie
eigentlich mehr fachpersonal entstehen
kann sie reden nicht über die
finanzierung die schweigen vor allem
über die notwendige umverteilung des
reichtums in diesem land das sind aber
die zutaten kolleginnen und kollegen das
sind die zutaten um die soziale spaltung
zu bekämpfen denn die
bildungsungerechtigkeit in deutschland
ist vor allem resultat der brutalen
einkommens und vermögensungleichheit in
diesem land daran wird die linke sie in
den nächsten vier jahren erinnern vielen
dank
nicole boote für die linksfraktion
endlich
parteifreundin der ministerin ria
schröder sie ist bildungspolitische
sprecherin der fdp fraktion neu im
deutschen bundestag und hält hier jetzt
auch ihre erste rede
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
bildungsministerin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
meine oma lebte immer nach der idee dass
ihre kinder es einmal besser haben
sollten in unserer von neuen krisen
geprägten zeit teilen viele diesen
leitgedanken nicht mehr finanzkrise
klimakrise corona krise manche haben den
glauben an das aufstiegsversprechen für
die nächste generation verloren und
andere sogar den anspruch daran kinder
und jugendliche standen gerade in der
pandemie oft an letzter stelle das muss
sich ändern und das werden wir ändern
meine damen und herren
112 tage waren die schulen im letzten
winter zwischen dezember und mai
geschlossen während die fußballstadien
schon wieder voll waren und wenn sich
jugendliche dann mal mit freunden im
park trafen dann konnte es ihnen
passieren dass sie von der polizei
befragt wurden wie im hamburger
jenischpark wo sind wir denn gelandet
was geben wir den jungen menschen heute
mit auf den weg die folgen dieser
politik waren verheerend
unaufholbare lern rückstände häusliche
gewalt psychische krankheiten bis hin zu
suizidversuchen die neue ampelkoalition
und die bundesbildungsministerin
haben hier einen klaren richtungswechsel
eingeleitet mit uns werden die nächsten
vier jahre der bildungspolitik geprägt
sein vom ziel jedem jungen menschen in
diesem land aufstiegschance zu
ermöglichen
ich freue mich ja über die große
zustimmung von der union das hätten sie
zwar die letzten 16 jahre schon umsetzen
können haben sie verloren aber
vorstellen sie haben auch die letzte
bildungsministerin frau carlitscheck
erwähnt aber nicht das desaster was sie
für die bildungspolitik in diesem land
war jänner mich zb dass sie nicht einmal
darüber nachgedacht hat das bafög als
krisenschutz für azubis und studierende
zu öffnen nicht einmal als die
jugendorganisationen der demokratischen
parteien jungen liberalen auf die junge
union war dabei sie darum gebeten haben
sie hat auf den gemeinsamen brief nicht
einmal geantwortet so viel desinteresse
und ignoranz gegenüber jungen menschen
darf nicht noch einmal die
bildungspolitik in diesem land bestimmen
wir wollen aber nicht nur aufräumen was
sie versäumt haben wir wollen nicht
weniger als allen kindern und
jugendlichen unabhängig vom elternhaus
vom wohnort von hautfarbe geschlecht
oder religion oder bundesland exzellente
bildung bieten denn das ist die
grundlage für ein selbstbestimmtes leben
meine damen und herren
werden wir das bafög eltern unabhängig
machen werden sie liegt den digital
packt verbessern und mit dem digital
pack 2.0 ein neues digitalisierungs
programm auf den weg bringen und wir
werden mit dem startchancen programm
mehr als 4000 schulen zu talent schulen
machen mit einem chancen budget das
modernste pädagogik und ausstattung
ermöglicht von endgeräten bis kreativ
laboren für bessere schulsozialarbeit
berufsorientierung und individuelle
förderung die besten schulen brauchen
wir da wo armut und soziale
herausforderungen am größten sind
eben wir kindern und jugendlichen das
handwerkszeug mit auf ihren lebensweg
mit dem sie in einer welt voller krisen
nicht den mut verlieren sondern lernen
ihre individuellen talente und
fähigkeiten zu nutzen um die
herausforderungen der zukunft anzupacken
wir haben es in den nächsten vier jahren
in der hand diese weichen zu stellen
denn wenn ich einmal oma bin dann möchte
ich sagen können wir haben dafür gesorgt
dass es unseren kindern bessergeht
und in diesem sinne freue ich mich frau
ministerin auf ihre arbeit wünsche
vielfältig und freue mich auf die
parlamentarische debatte hier und danke
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
julia schröder mit ihrer ersten rede im
deutschen bundestag sie ist der
bildungspolitik die bildungspolitische
sprecherin der fdp-fraktion und sie sagt
der armut und soziale herausforderungen
da wo die am größten sind da muss auch
beste bildung hin thomas jarzombek ist
der nächste redner als bildungs und
forschungspolitischer sprecher der
cdu/csu-fraktion
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe frau bundesministerin ich
darf ihnen ganz herzlich gratulieren zu
ihrer neuen aufgabe und ich darf ihnen
besonders dazu gratulieren dass sie
dieses ministerium bekommen haben denn
sie bekommen ein ausgesprochen gut
bestelltes haus der ausschuss der
aufschwung der mitte meine damen und
herren den wert der letzten 16 jahren
gesehen haben ist beispiellos auch für
alle anderen politikfeldern
wir sind bei
7,6 milliarden gestartet und
mittlerweile bei fast 21 milliarden euro
eine fast verdreifachung in keinem
anderen politikfeld kann man das so
sagen bei uns hatte wissenschaft
forschung und bildung immer priorität
ein benchmark es liegt jetzt an ihnen
diese linie auch weiterzuentwickeln
das ist das entscheidende
wir sind deutlich über die 3 prozent
gekommen bei den forschungsausgaben sie
haben das ziel 35 das vereint und
übrigens verein uns viele dinge aus
ihrem programm aber es wird am ende
darauf ankommen ob sie es wirklich
machen und ob sie das zusätzliche geld
bekommen das ist die messlatte und was
ich in ihrer rede frau ministerin
vermisst habe ist das wort des privaten
kapitals an der stelle weil die
forschungsausgaben bestehen ja nicht nur
aus den staatlichen mitteln so einen
größeren teil aus den privaten mit und
da wenn ich gespannt auf ihre ideen wie
sie das erreichen sein wir haben dazu
gute dinge in der letzten periode
vorgelegt der staat als anker kunden ein
gutes thema gerade für den
forschungsbereich wir haben für elf
millionen euro staats bei einer
raumfahrt firma bestellt die hat
daraufhin
155 millionen euro privates kapital
eingesammelt dass ein hebel das kann ein
vorbild sein in quantencomputern bereich
das gleich 40 millionen euro zuletzt von
anja karliczek vergeben an ein startup
an
und damit komme ich zu dem nächsten
punkt den ich in ihrem vortrag bisher
noch vermisst aber gestoppt werden wir
noch ein bisschen strecke auch vor uns
das wort start-ups weil ich glaube ohne
start ups werden wir kein typ jak
ökosystem bauen und das müssen wir tun
wir haben hier einiges in den letzten
jahren geschafft wir haben erfolgreiche
start-ups die raketen bauen neu in
deutschland
wir sind weltweit führend was das thema
flugzeug sissi vitrolles betrifft wir
haben's start ups im bereich kernfusion
wir haben mit biontech zum ersten mal
wieder ein dieb text start up was
wirklich global ein infekt macht und das
ist eben das ergebnis von 16 jahren
unionsgeführter forschungspolitik von
unseren mitteln von der hightech
strategie der exzellenzinitiative dass
wir es schaffen solche wissenschaftler
und forscher wieder in deutschland zu
halten die in der vergangenheit
abgewandert sind und da gibt es viel zu
tun ein weiteres stichwort was sich in
ihrer rede gerne gehört hätte es das
wort mittelstadt denn forschung wird nur
funktionieren mit dem mittelstand
gemeinsam wir können uns nicht auf die
großen konzerne verlassen im gegenteil
wir brauchen hier wettbewerb wettbewerb
zwischen start-ups zwischen
mittelständlern und hier muss ein klarer
schwerpunkt her und ich darf das schon
einmal ankündigen wir werden auf der
strecke danach fragen wir werden danach
fragen wie viele ausgaben geben sie für
den mittelstand aus bei forschung und
technologie und wir brauchen auch
instrumente um hier im transfer besser
zu werden mit privatem kapital
der staat darf nicht alleine ins risiko
gehen sie haben ein projekt benannt die
die deutsche agentur für technologien
und innovation die wird welche frage
wird sein wie konkret wird das
eigentlich ausgestaltet wir haben bei
der swiss übrigens auch ein wort was ich
in ihrer rede von mist habe was wird
eigentlich aus der sprint
bei der sprints bei der sprint gibt es
dinge zu tun das ist so aber wir machen
hier auch eine gemeinsame lernkurve und
die gemeinsame lernkurve aus der sprint
sagt die dinge werden kein selbstläufer
und wenn sie jetzt auch eine neue
agentur gründen waren in one out weniger
regulierung bürokratie ist immer ein
thema der fdp gewesen wollen wir auch
wissen was schaffen sie dafür eigentlich
ab weil ständig neue agenturen zu
gründen dass es am ende eben keine lust
wir haben große regulatorische aufgaben
wenn wir bei christa klein anfangen bis
hin zu der frage lassen die neue
nukleartechnologien zu künstliche
intelligenz sämtliche gehen fragen wir
haben so viele themen wo sie sich als
koalition auch klar werden müssen was
sie wollen wollen sie dinge ermöglichen
oder wollen sie dinge verbieten im
verbieten war in der vergangenheit was
die union stand für diesen kurs nie wir
waren immer für wir waren immer für
offenheit und technologie und ich glaube
dass wir mit der
es interessant dass gerade die grünen
beim thema verbote lachen diva kollege
dr -ing das möchte ich an der stelle mal
sagen die verbotsliste ihrer partei ist
auch legendär und wir haben auch beim
thema bafög 1,3 milliarden mehr locker
gemacht wir werden das gemeinsam neu aus
gestalten müssen das ist glaube ich auch
klar aber wenn sie von
elternunabhängiges bafög reden wird sich
natürlich die frage stellen glauben wir
auch ein subsidiarität oder bekommen
eben auch diejenigen geld des staates
die nun weiß gott von zu hause so viel
geld mitbringen dass sie es nicht
brauchen
zuletzt
zuletzt wünsche ich mir für die für die
digitalisierung der schule auch mehr
offenheit und wetter ab sie werden
zeigen müssen wie sie das grundgesetz
wirklich ändern wollen weil eins ist
doch klar wir werden hier mehr machen
wollen und müssen aber wir werden nicht
unkonditioniert geld an länder geben
können und das wird eine schwierige
aufgabe wir werden ihre partner dabei
sein wir werden aber auch kritisch
begleiten es kann ja kein
unkonditioniert das geld diese
grundgesetzänderung die sie ja auch
implizit angekündigt haben wird ein
großes thema werden der fachkräftemangel
ist ein großes thema wenn sie auf
unseren initiativen zur beruflichen
bildung aufsetzen ist das gut und
wichtig an dieser stelle und wir müssen
digitalisierungen die bildung
hineinbringen wir brauchen plattformen
wo auch neue anbieter startups
reinkommen wo es wettbewerb gibt wo pro
klick bezahlt wird und nicht
schulbuchverlage über viele jahre
sichere erträge bekommt die keine
innovation anreizen und ein letzter
punkt wir brauchen noch mehr dialog und
wenn ich den kollegen sattelberger auf
der regierungsbank sehr hat er learning
analytics am wochenende angekündigt
finde ich gut habe ich dreimal gefragt
wer denn damit meint habe ich keine
antwort bekommen herr kollege sie haben
auch zu ihrem hund getwittert der ist
zweifelsohne süßer als die
wissenschaftsthemen dazu gratuliere ich
ihnen da waren sie deutlich
auskunftsfreudiger ich glaube hier
brauchen wir auch einen dialog zwischen
regierung und opposition den wünsche ich
mir im parlament wie auf anderen ebenen
viel erfolg alles gute wir werden wir
was erreichen
thomas jarzombek war dass die
bildungs und forschungspolitische
sprecher der unions fraktion in dieser
legislaturperiode hat ein paar
ausführungen bei der ministerin vermisst
zum thema förderung von start ups zum
beispiel aber vielleicht muss man
fairerweise auch dazu sagen die
ministerinnen haben hier für ihre
ausführungen fünf vielleicht mal sieben
minuten zeit der wenn sie natürlich
nicht vollständig hervorgehen können was
sie in dieser legislaturperiode vorhaben
nichts desto trotz ist die anmerkung von
thomas jarzombek natürlich legitim
katrin schau ist die nächste rednerin
aus der spd fraktion
was erleben unsere kinder und
jugendlichen nach wie vor in die zeiten
der pandemie oder vielmehr was bleibt
ihnen verwehrt
wurde und wird das wohl von kindern und
jugendlichen während der pandemie
besonders bedacht und ausreichend
berücksichtigt diese frage adressiert
unter anderem das deutsche
kinderhilfswerk auch an uns abgeordnete
grundsätzlich und zuerst sage ich wer
wirklich will dass kinder und
jugendliche wieder einen normalen schul
und kita alltag ergeben können neben
daran liegt dass die nachmittags in
ihren sportvereinen oder zum vorgehen
können wer möchte dass der
schwimmunterricht nicht ausfällt das
schul fragt nicht mehr verschoben werden
wer will dass abschluss feiern
stattfinden junge leute nicht zu hause
sondern im klassenverband und in
seminaren an der universität gemeinsam
lernen können wer will dass sie wieder
in clubs und auf festivals tanzen gehen
der oder die sollte jetzt losgehen und
sich impfen lassen wer sich als
erwachsener gäste
unterstützt damit kinder und jugendlich
und bringt ihnen die normalität zurück
zweitens füge ich hinzu die leerstände
die nach der langen lockdown phase
erhoben worden sind fallen ergebnis
stark auseinander die kontinuierliche
kompetenzentwicklung ganzer schuljahre
fehlt nun leider und schlägt sich auch
in der berufsbildung nieder nach einem
ohnehin kräftezehrenden schuljahr voller
belastung einschränken und kurzfristig
wechselnden rahmenbedingungen hatten
unsere lehrkräfte und erzieher und
erzieherinnen nur wenig zeit
insbesondere kinder aus haushalten mit
wenig formaler bildung und ökonomischen
ressourcen beim aufholen und
weiterlernen nach corona unter die arme
zu greifen
auch deshalb ist es jetzt wichtig die
schulen weiterhin abgesichert offen zu
halten
die korona pandemie noch einmal deutlich
ausgeleuchtet was im bildungsbereich in
den nächsten jahren angepackt werden
muss wir haben uns als ampel koalition
vorgenommen die 2020er jahre zu einem
jahrzehnte zukunftsinvestitionen
insbesondere in klimaschutz in
digitalisierung in bildung und forschung
und infrastruktur zu machen die
bildungsinstitution schule spielt eine
entscheidende rolle sie kann alle kinder
und jugendlichen erreichen und durch
zeitgemäße und gute pädagogik dazu
beitragen kinder und jugendliche
unabhängig von ihrer herkunft zu fördern
und bildungsungerechtigkeit in
deutschland endlich zu verringern unser
bemühen muss ich darauf ausrichten
jungen menschen so auszubilden dass sie
sich in einer rasant verändernden
digitalen welt zurechtfinden und
behaupten können was wollen wir in
dieser hinsicht unter anderem gemeinsam
anpacken im anschluss an das krone
aufholt paket werden wir die situation
für kinder und jugendliche mit einem
zukunftspaket für bewegung kultur und
gesundheit schnell und wirksam
verbessern und auch ich wenn es erwähnen
mit dem neuen programm start chancen
wollen wir kindern und jugendlichen
bessere bildungschancen unabhängig von
der sozialen lage ihre eltern
ermöglichen wir werden dabei mehr als
4000 allgemein und berufsbildende
schulen mit einem hohen anteil sozial
benachteiligte schülerinnen und schüler
besonders stärken wir unterstützen diese
schulen dauerhaft in das ich richtig
dauerhaft mit stellen für
schulsozialarbeit
gemeinsam mit den ländern werden die ein
digital pack 2.0 für schulen mit einer
laufzeit bis 2030 auf den weg bringen
und dieser digital pakt wird auch die
nachhaltige neuanschaffung von hardware
den austausch veralteter technik sowie
geräte wartung und administration
umfassen die qualitätsoffensive
lehrerbildung entwickeln wir mit neuen
schwerpunkten weiter unter anderem zu
digitaler bildung und wir richten den
fokus auf digital ist und digital
gestütztes unterrichten in schule und
weiterbildung
bundesprogramme dürfe nicht zu spät um
so wie wir es zuletzt beim digital packt
schule erlebt haben darüber hinaus soll
ihre beantragung und der mittelabruf
nicht mit überbordendem bürokratischen
aufwand verbunden sein diese optimierung
von bund länder programm die wir uns
vorgenommen haben stellt aber nur einen
sehr wichtigen aspekt dar wir streben
grundsätzlich die schon erwähnte engere
zielgenaueren verbindliche kooperationen
aller ebenen an und wollen eine neue
kultur in der bildungszusammenarbeit
begründen im koalitionsvertrag ist
vereinbart dass wir einen bildungsgipfel
einberufen auf dem sich bund länder
kommunen wissenschaft und
zivilgesellschaft über neue formen der
zusammenarbeit und gemeinsame
ambitionierte bildungsziele verständigen
und fragen des bildungswesens bewegen
eine nämlich der größten gemeinsamen
bildungspolitischen herausforderung ist
der hohe lehrkräfte bedarf und der
fachkräftebedarf bei den
erziehungsberufen in den kommenden
jahren es muss darum gehen dass auch in
zukunft genügend gut qualifizierte und
motivierte lehrkräfte und erzieherinnen
und erzieher in schule und kita arbeiten
nur auf dieser grundlage ist es überdies
überhaupt möglich eine senkung der
arbeitsbelastung der kolleginnen und
kollegen herbei zu führen sehr geehrter
abgeordnet
wir wollen im bund verantwortung mehr
verantwortung für bildungsqualität
koordinationen finanzierung übernehmen
kinder und jugendliche beim lernen in
der pandemie und beim aufholen
unterstützen ich freue mich auf die
zusammenarbeit mit ihnen allen
patente war das für die spd im ausschuss
für bildung forschung und
technikfolgenabschätzung
der bundestag diskutiert weiterhin das
ressort bildung und forschung und die
vorhaben der neuen ministerin bettina
stark watzinger nächster redner coach
fleming aus der afg fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren wir alle waren
sehr gespannt als es um die verteilung
der ressorts geht an wen das so wichtige
ministerium für bildung und forschung
wohl gehen würde nun nun es liegt in den
händen der fdp
und frau ministerin ich darf mir die
bemerkung erlauben mit blick auf ihren
koalitionspartner es hätte schlimmer
kommen können meine damen und herren
das bedeutet aber auch dass sie frau
ministerin das wirklich auch umsetzen
was sie vorhin angekündigt haben sie
sprachen nämlich ja von
technologieoffenheit von einem
deutlichen bekenntnis zur forschung und
da sehe ich doch mit blick auf die grüne
partei erhebliche vorbehalte
insbesondere was die erforschung der so
wichtigen technologie umgehen
technischen bereich anbelangt genauso
großer dann noch größer sind die
vorbehalte bei der erforschung sogar bei
der erforschung der kernenergie an meine
damen und herren wir müssen doch nur zu
unseren europäischen nachbarn blicken um
zu sehen dass der deutsche sonderweg
hier falsches wir sollten schnell auf
die linie unsere europäischen partner
ein strenger einschränken und
kernenergie nicht mehr zum tabu erklären
meine damen und herren sie haben es
vielleicht gelesen vor wenigen tagen
stand in den zeitungen dass deutschland
mal wieder weltmeister ist leider in
einer zweifelhaften disziplin wir sind
nämlich weltmeister im erlassen von
verboten und maßnahmen um die bürger zu
einem pandemie konformen verhalten zu
bewegen nun könnte ja man mit diesem
titel noch zufrieden sein wenn auf der
anderen seite der medaille stünde dass
wir besonders gut durch die pandemie
gekommen wären aber da sehen wir dass
länder die beispielsweise die schulen
viel kürzer nur geschlossen haben als
wir frankreich etwa kam mit 50 tagen aus
schweden nur mit etwa 30 tagen bei uns
sind es summa summarum über 180 tage
gewesen diese länder sind eben nicht
wesentlich schlechter durch die pandemie
und meine damen und herren sie alle
waren gewarnt nicht nur von uns von der
fdp fraktion ich selbst habe darauf
hingewiesen von diesem podium aus wir
hatten frühzeitig auch studien
beispielsweise der uniklinik hamburg
kops ii studie sie haben sie ignoriert
sie haben weiter schulen schüler
drangsaliert und jetzt haben wir die
erschreckenden ergebnisse schauen sie
sich an was die neue studie der
uniklinik essen hervor gebracht hat die
suizidversuche von jugendlichen von
kindern und schülern sind während der
pandemie explodiert sie liegen drei bis
viermal so hoch wie in anderen zeiten
und meine damen und herren das ist auch
ein ergebnis ihrer einseitigen ihrer
überzogenen politik und sie werden sich
dafür vor den kindern und ihren eltern
verantworten müssen
[Applaus]
frau ministerin einer ihrer neuen
parlamentarischen staatssekretäre gefiel
sich immer darin unsere ihre vorgängerin
etwas despektierlich
aufzufordern am schluss seiner rede mit
der formel ran an den speck frau kali
check nun jetzt sitzt die spd selber in
dem haus wo der speck verteilt wird frau
ministerin wir werden sie dabei
begleiten kritisch begleiten wünschen
aber ihnen und auch natürlich ihren
parlamentarischen staatssekretären viel
erfolg bei dieser wichtigen aufgabe
ich danke
das war götz frühling aus der
fdp-fraktion das was er eben vorgetragen
hat mit suizidversuchen von kindern in
der pandemie das schauen wir uns in den
nächsten minuten hier noch mal genauer
an und verweisen aber zunächst auf die
nächste rednerin an jahr ein alter aus
der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen auch
sie tritt zum aller ersten mal an das
rednerpult im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
und auch gute zusammenarbeit
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ja wir
haben es heute schon öfter gehört wir
befinden uns mitten in der
transformation der wirtschaft und die
aus- und weiterbildung spielt hierbei
eine schlüsselrolle
und dabei geht es um nichts weniger als
um menschen um ihr wissen um ihre
handwerklichen fähigkeiten um ihre
motivation und ihre leidenschaft jeden
tag ihr bestes zu geben
und natürlich geht es um unseren
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland
denn unsere unternehmen brauchen gut
ausgebildete menschen und derzeit fehlen
sie
der fachkräftemangel
das bundesweit bekannte realität er wird
auch nicht einfach verschwinden und da
wird auch von niemand geleugnet im
gegenteil die geburtenstarken jahrgänge
der baby boomer gehen demnächst in den
ruhestand das ist das eine die
wirtschaftliche transformation die wir
für unser klima so dringend brauchen das
ist das andere und allein für letzteres
benötigen wir immer mehr fachleute
insbesondere im handwerk und das ist
aber auch die positive nachricht denn
die transformation ist wirklich eine
große herausforderung sie bietet aber
auch chancen
chancen für spannende neue berufliche
perspektiven und
darum bieten wir jetzt ein
zukunftsfähiges
berufsbildungssystem ein
berufsbildungssystem das auf der höhe
der gesellschaftlichen realität arbeitet
im koalitionsvertrag
haben wir uns auf eine vielzahl von
maßnahmen geeinigt es greife 3 heraus
erstens werden wir betriebe unterstützen
bei der suche nach azubis in dem wir die
berufsorientierung und die jugend berufs
eigentor und weiter ausbauen und an
dieser stelle bedanke ich mich recht
herzlich bei allen unternehmen und
betrieben die ihren beitrag zu deren
ausbildung leisten herzlichen dank dafür
zweitens werden wir die
ausbildungsgarantie sicherstellen denn
wir können es uns nicht leisten dass wir
talente verlieren
und drittens die weiterbildung ist
wichtiger denn je und sollte
selbstverständlicher bestandteil der
arbeit und dem biografie sein
und darum setzen wir auf fort und
weiterbildung aller berufsgruppen und
aller branchen und waren des aufstiegs
bafög und das weiterbildungsgeld weiter
ausbauen denn wir brauchen mehr master
und mehr meister sehr geehrte damen und
herren
und besonders wichtig ist uns auch dass
wir die menschen erreichen die vom
strukturwandel betroffen sind und die
sich neue berufsfelder suchen müssen
denn es ist gut damit darum ist das
jetzt gut das leben andere
koalitionsvertrag mit der
ausbildungsgarantie mit dem aufstieg
perfekt mit dem weiterbildungsgeld die
richtigen instrumente festgelegt haben
so können wir den fachkräftemangel
begegnen viele menschen unterstützen die
herausforderungen der zukunft zu
meistern
und dafür sind wir liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen alle gefragt also lassen sie
uns gemeinsam an einem strang ziehen und
loslegen herzlichen dank für das spiel
an ihr ein alter war das und das heißt
er wird jetzt petra sitte folgen aus der
fraktion die linke petra sitte ist
stellvertretender vorsitzender
ebenda
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die große koalition ist jetzt will die
ampel koalition wie der titel ihres
koalitionsvertrages verrät mehr
fortschritt wagen ich zitiere wir wollen
unser land erneut in die zukunft
investieren und innovation fördern damit
wir unseren wohlstand erhalten und
ausbauen können und frau ministerin
sagte bildung und forschung seien
treiber des wohlstandes berner jetzt
gerade versucht hat zu klatschen dem
will ich nur sagen es ist interessant
weil der satz stammt nämlich nicht aus
ihrer koalitionsvereinbarung sondern aus
der koalitionsvereinbarung von union und
spd
und warum ist das so interessant weil
wir uns nämlich fragen wenn wir ihren
koalitionsvertrag betrachten was macht
denn jetzt das neue aus was ist denn ja
neue
duktus das ist der neue geist dieser
koalitionsvereinbarung welchen
fortschritt welchen und dessen wohlstand
sollen denn wissenschaft und forschung
vor allem voran bringen die linke hat
immer betont es geht zuallererst um eine
gemeinwohlorientierung wieso zur
ökonomischen ökologisch und
gesellschaftlichen herausforderungen
lassen auch gar nichts anderes zu an
konzepten zur überwindung beispielsweise
der schere zwischen arm und reich von
energiekrisen und preis explosion oder
zum ausbau der sozialsysteme
dazu muss vor allem geforscht werden wir
stellen fest beim lesen ihres
koalitionsvertrages sie reden nur von
einem neuen geist aber ein wirklich
neuer ansatz in man dem von mir
genannten sinne der fehlt dieser
koalitionsvereinbarung stattdessen mehr
programme neue strukturen noch mehr
projekte sämtlich zeitlich befristet das
heißt alles ist wichtig und alles nichts
es droht die vollständige zersplitterung
der forschungs und technologieförderung
auch in zukunft werden dann also
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
massenweise ressourcen in
antragsverfahren ohne ende stecken
müssen die unterfinanzierung von
hochschulen und universitäten wird genau
diese konkurrenz noch verschärfen was
ist vor allem notwendig langfristige und
verlässliche finanzierung des
gesamtsystems
mir persönlich ist anschließend
abschließend ist auch wichtig dass es
nicht nur darum geht über start-ups zu
reden reden sie bitte auch über die
vorhandenen forschenden mittelständler
sprechen sie über das zentrale
innovationsprogramm mittelstand und
möchten sie darüber wie sie den in einem
fairen wettbewerb bieten damit hier
bessere lebens und
beschäftigungsbedingungen entstehen
petra sitte aus der linksfraktion und
ich hatte ihnen gesagt wir schauen auch
mal nach was zu den zahlen zu sagen ist
die wird frühling vorhin in seinem
beitrag bezüglich suizidversuchen von
kindern während der pandemie
aufgelistet hat eine auflistung aus
essen und dazu muss man sagen dass es
dieses thema tatsächlich gibt es ist
auch überhaupt nichts zu beschönigen
allerdings warnen experten und
insbesondere
eine vorstände in der deutschen
gesellschaft für kinder und
jugendpsychiatrie darauf dass diese
studien noch nicht überprüft ist also
die zahlen sind noch nicht gegen
gecheckt worden die zahlen sind auch
noch nicht offiziell veröffentlicht
worden und bis dahin so sagt sie solle
man doch recht zurückhaltend über diese
inhalte sprechen unter scheint sich mehr
beide oder scheint mir wichtig bei
diesem thema auch tatsächlich eigentlich
ganz wichtiger punkt so sein dass man
erstmal abwartet was davon tatsächlich
belastbar und verifizierbare ist bevor
man mit solchen mit solchen zahlen dann
an die öffentlichkeit geht
nichtsdestotrotz auch das noch mal dazu
gesagt das problem ist tatsächlich da ob
es in dieser größenordnung des weges vor
hingehört haben das muss noch dringlich
überprüft werden denn da gibt es
durchaus methodische fragen die noch
hinterfragt werden müssen wir gehen
wieder zurück in den plenarsaal hat so
meyer waldstein für die spd mitglied im
ausschuss für bildung und forschung
natürlich darauf ankommen dass wir auch
taten sprechen lassen und wir haben uns
viel vorgenommen wir wollen mehr
fortschritt wagen und liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich erlaube mir zu sagen es
wird zeit für uns als spd bedeutet
fortschritt auch die hochschulen in
ihrer vielfalt zu stärken denn sie sind
der kern und das herzstück unseres
wissenschaftssystems
hochschulen werben zum beispiel spitzen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
an sie betreiben grundlagenforschung bis
hin zur anwendung und sie bilden
zukünftige generationen aus die
hochschulen sind darüber hinaus oftmals
arbeitgeber und
innovationsmotor ihrer region wir wollen
die hochschulen stärken und wir wollen
als koalition dafür richtig geld in die
hand nehmen und wir werden deshalb den
zukunftsvertrag studium und lehre
dynamisieren wir werden die jährlichen
zuwendung um drei prozent steigern das
war der letzte koalition leider nicht zu
machen ich bin froh dass wir das jetzt
sicherstellen dass sich die budgets der
forschungsorganisation und der
hochschulen nicht weiter
auseinanderentwickeln
denn spitze porsche findet nicht nur an
den außeruniversitären statt wir haben
exzellente forschung an unseren
hochschulen und die muss auch weiterhin
gefördert werden und unsere koalition
hat vereinbart die exzellenz strategie
weiterzuentwickeln
wir stehen dabei für wissenschafts und
wettbewerbs geleitetes verfahren wir
stellen die weichen um die
antragstellung von verbünden für
kooperative und interdisziplinäre
exzellenzcluster zu stärken und auch
wenn die förderentscheidung erst in der
nächsten legislatur getroffen werden
müssen wir schon jetzt sicherstellen
dass die exzellenz strategie auch
zukünftig ein aushängeschild der
spitzenforschung bleibt
außerdem wollen wir die forschung an
fachhochschulen stärken unter anderem
mit der gründung der daten darauf wird
meine geschätzte kollegin julie gleich
genauer eingehen wir wollen so das
potenzial heben und sichtbar machen dass
manchmal ein wenig im schatten der
leuchttürme liegt
region die vom wandel besonders
betroffen sind ist dieser
koalitionsvertrag eine gute nachricht
und das glauben bei mir zu hause in der
lausitz auf den ersten blick nicht alle
sofort weil natürlich auch denn
möglicher vorgezogener kohleausstieg
drin steht und ich weiß genau woher
diese skepsis kommt weil ich ganz genau
erlebe was das für die menschen bedeutet
und übrigens nicht zum ersten mal wir
müssen und wir werden alles daran setzen
um ein gutes leben und industrielle
wertschöpfung vor ort zu erhalten
der vielleicht wichtigste baustein dafür
sind zukunftstechnologien darum bin ich
überzeugt dass das klare bekenntnis
unserer koalition zu innovationsregion
zu experimentieren räumen die größte
chance ist die wir seit jahren haben bei
uns in der lausitz im osten aber für die
ganze republik vor allem
damit uns das aber gelingt damit wir
vorankommen global mitspielen können und
attraktiv sind für spitzen
wissenschaftlerinnen für die wirtschaft
müssen wir als gesellschaft stabil
bleiben die bedeutung der wissenschaft
und forschung für eine freie innovative
und offene gesellschaft ist dabei nicht
zu überschätzen wir müssen ein land sein
das sich für wissenschaftsfreiheit
einsetzt und diese immer wieder
verteidigt wir müssen einen landtag dass
ich nicht abschottet das anerkennt wie
wertvoll der internationale austausch
für innovation für entwicklung ist
braucht zusammenhalt
und darum müssen wir ein land sein das
diskussionsfreudig bleibt und in dem
jede und jeder sein und ihre eigene
meinung hat aber nicht seine eigenen
fakten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
wünsche mir dass wir uns auch in diesem
punkt zumindest einig sind und in diesem
sinne auf eine gute zusammenarbeit
[Applaus]
maja waldstein und ihr folgt dann jeder
ludwig aus der cdu/csu-fraktion aus ist
mitglied im ausschuss für bildung
forschung und technikfolgenabschätzung
und zur abwechslung mal keiner die neu
im parlament ist
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich sag's gern noch einmal
liebe frau ministerin wir gratulieren
ihnen zu ihrem neuen amt wir gratulieren
ihnen aber auch dazu dass sie ein
wohlbestelltes haus übernehmen und das
meine ich sehr sehr ernst und das nicht
nur weil es uns
unionsgeführte gelungen ist die mittel
für forschung und entwicklung mehr als
zu verdoppeln
es ist nicht nur natürlich eine frage
der mittel aber es ist nicht ganz
unwesentlich dass wir eine wichtige
vorlage machen von der sie hoffentlich
auch noch weiter profitieren werden wir
haben aber auch
materiell rechtlichen zb dinge getan wie
das aufstiegs bafög in die wege geleitet
ein absolutes erfolgsmodell bisher
wurden neun milliarden euro in dieses
instrument gesteckt 2,8 millionen
menschen haben bereits davon profitiert
übrigens ein drittel frauen
auch nicht ganz unwichtig an dieser
stelle etwas was wir liebe kollegin
schön vorangebracht haben in der letzten
legislatur und
wir haben das berufsbildungs
modernisierungsgesetz auf den weg
gebracht das war auch ein relativ dickes
brett es hat lang gedauert dass wir
dieses thema wieder ran gegangen sind
wir sind damit anfang 20 20 gestartet
und wir haben damit die so wichtige
berufliche ausbildung fit gemacht für
die zukunft und das ist wichtig denn wir
brauchen auch weiterhin in deutschland
eine stärkung der beruflichen bildung
fortschreitende digitalisierung
neuartige
kommunikationsformen sind
herausforderungen die jeden von uns ein
leben lang begleiten und wo wir alle
nicht nur fit werden müssen am anfang
des beruflichen lebens sondern wo wir
fit bleiben müssen und das ist etwas was
uns als union weiterhin auch in dieser
legislatur massiv um treiben wird
nur diese beiden instrumente genommen
sie sind von der community fast schon
gefeiert worden weil sie lange erwartet
wurden und sie werden weiterhin
erfolgreich umgesetzt und sie sind
sicherlich auch ein wichtiges mittel um
den viel zitierten fachkräftemangel in
unserem land zu bekämpfen
der fachkräftemangel ist in den leider
nur eine einzige erwähnung wert in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag das finde ich schade
und auch das thema bildung ist mit vier
seiten nach meinem dafürhalten etwas
unterbelichtet aber der kollege
jarzombek sagt er so schön wir haben
noch ein bisschen wegstrecke vor uns und
so wie ich sie heute verstanden habe
haben sie einiges vor ich möchte auch
ganz ganz klar dafür werden dass wir
weiterhin an dem kurs festhalten dass es
nicht nur akademische bildung gibt es
von vielen von ihnen ja schon gesorgt
worden sondern dass mindestens
gleichwertige berufliche bildung daneben
stehen muss das ist unser
herzensanliegen
sie bitte ihr augenmerk darauf dass
junge menschen sich für handwerksberufe
entscheiden dass sie sich dafür
entscheiden facharbeiter zu werden dass
sie in diese richtung gehen handwerk hat
gold im mund ist wo der alte kalauer ich
glaube gott die zeiten die wir im moment
erleben beweisen ist ganz ganz deutlich
dass es genau so ist wir haben hier
tatsächlich in den letzten jahren
einiges voran bringen können und ich
möchte sie wirklich herzlich bitten
gehen sie diesen weg weiter denn da
können sehr sehr viele junge menschen
tatsächlich davon profitieren was
wichtiges es beim thema ausbildung und
beruflicher bildung das natürlich das
matching von angebot und nachfrage dass
uns umtreibt also zwischen denen die
einen ausbildungs platz suchen und denen
die einen auszubildenden suchen besser
klappen muss die antwort kann aber nicht
sein
alles nur in die außerbetriebliche
ausbildung ob zu drücken denn ich glaube
es ist schon wichtig dass sich junge
leute auch weiterhin mit ihrem
ausbildungsbetrieb identifizieren und
dass sie optimalerweise nach ende der
ausbildung nicht sofort den absprung
versuchen woanders sind sondern dass sie
vielleicht auch ein paar jährchen in
diesem betrieb worden der sie
ausgebildet hat und da profitieren beide
davon und deswegen nicht nur zu sehr den
fokus legen auf die außerbetriebliche
ausbildung sondern wirklich gucken das
leistungs stück weit zusammen bleibt
auch nach abschluss der ausbildung
und deswegen sind wir sehr gespannt was
sich hinter ausbildungsgarantie um so
weiter dann letztlich verbirgt die fdp
hat sich auch noch dafür feiern lassen
die ausbildungsumlage zu verhindern ich
bin jetzt gespannt wie das tor am ende
des tages zusammen gehen soll wir freuen
uns jedenfalls hier vielleicht weiter
mit gehen zu dürfen thema weiterbildung
lebenslanges lernen erlaubt die zeit
nicht hier doch darauf einzugehen aber
auch das ist natürlich ein wichtiger
baustein für den innovations- und
zukunftsstandort deutschland um den wir
uns kümmern müssen wir sind gerne dabei
da wo wir helfen können aber wir werden
natürlich auch den finger in die wunde
legen wenn wir den eindruck haben jetzt
läuft es falsch ich freue mich auf die
zusammenarbeit vielen herzlichen dank
daniela ludwig und auch mit ihr nähern
wir uns schon den beiden vorletzten
rednerinnen in dieser debatte und dann
geht es ja erst mal eine kleine
unterbrechung geben im bundestag mit
überweisungen und walen die uns nicht so
besonders intensiv beschäftigen werden
aber es gibt ja auch andere themen in
der welt deswegen weil wir dann
vorübergehend klima dem bundestag
verlassen aber noch ist es nicht soweit
zunächst eine weitere premieren rede
nämlich von laura kraft aus der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen sie ist obfrau im
ausschuss für bildung und forschung
nach 16 jahren verpasste chancen kommt
von der cdu 0 selbstkritik und viel
unverdientes selbstlob das ist
beachtlich denn
im schnitt studierende für akademiker
kindern werden bis unter den
arbeiterkindern nur eines von vieren ist
und dabei ist bildung eine der besten
investitionen die ein staat tätigen kann
wurde in der vergangenheit nur allzu oft
gespart ist es nun an der zeit endlich
die richtigen weichen zu stellen
zu echter chancengleichheit gehört ein
bafög das auch leistet was es soll ein
studium unabhängig von der sozialen
herkunft ermöglichen damit bafög
gerechter wird sorgen wir dafür dass
studierende unabhängiger von ihrem
elternhaus gefördert werden
erhöht die parkplätze klänge die
förderungsdauer und erleichtern und
digitalisieren das antragsverfahren
die situation von studierenden hat sich
in der pandemie dramatisch verschärft
viele mussten ihr studium verlängern
einige brachen ist ganz ab oder haben
das geplante studium erst gar nicht
begonnen
studierende sind angesichts der
anhaltenden pandemie von zukunftsangst
vom psychischer belastung und von
finanzieller not besonders betroffen und
hier sind wir als politik gefragt
soziale härten abzufedern und
die hochschulen sie sind das herzstück
des wissenschaftssystems gute forschung
und lehre die gelingt nur mit
auskömmlicher finanzieller rückendeckung
und deswegen werden wir in den kommenden
jahren die staatlichen ausgaben für
forschung und entwicklung erheblich
erhöhen
und indem wir die digitalisierung
voranbringen begleiten wir den
hochschulstandort deutschland in
richtung zukunft
wissenschaft und forschung sie sind
elementar für die lösung heutiger und
künftiger herausforderungen aber gute
forschung und gute forschung braucht
zeit und deshalb deshalb ermöglichen wir
faire arbeitsbedingungen und planbare
karrierewege für machen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
beschaffen dauer stellt für dauer-
aufkam und dazu gehört auch eine längst
eine längst überfällige reform des
wissenschafts zeitvertrag gesetzes
von emissionsfreier energieerzeugung
über künstliche intelligenz bis zum
impfstoff die erkenntnisse aus
wissenschaft und forschung sie prägen
unsere gesellschaft sie können unser
leben verändern sie retten es manchmal
sogar und für einen echten innovation
boost da wollen wir ausgründungen aus
hochschulen vorantreiben um das
potenzial des heimischen innovations-
und forschungsstandortes voll
auszuschöpfen
auf politischer ebene schaffen wir auch
mit ihnen frau ministerin dafür die
rahmenbedingungen und wir gestalten von
hier an zukunft vielen dank
laura kraft mögliche zukunft gestalten
das ist doch mal generell ein gutes
ansehen laura kraft war
oder vor lauter kraft was die erste rede
im bundestag und sie es war die
vorletzte rewe in dieser debatte eine
art generaldebatte über das zum zu den
themen und aufgabenstellung des ressorts
bildung und forschung wir haben eingangs
ja auch die bundesbildungsministerin
bettina stark watzinger gehört hier sind
bei der letzten rednerin jemanden aus
der spd-fraktion auch sie hält sie ahnen
dass ein klein wenig ihre erste rede ich
hier und heute
präsidentin sehr geehrte frau ministerin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
stehen im weißen kittel in einem labor
sie haben eine geniale idee diese führt
zu einer neuen entdeckung oder erfindung
zu neuen erkenntnissen und bestenfalls
sofort zu einer spürbaren verbesserung
von prozessen und produkten so stellen
sich viele menschen forschung vor das
gegenteil ist jedoch häufig der fall es
gibt die geniale ideen ja und davon
viele aber nur sehr selten wird eine
idee direkt umgesetzt und genauso selten
gelingen versuche und experimente im
ersten anlauf in wissenschaft und
forschung gibt es nicht nur erfolge viel
häufiger prägen rückschläge zweifel und
sogar frust den arbeitsalltag
wissenschaft und forschung bedeutet in
der praxis nicht aufzugeben es immer
wieder zu versuchen es bedeutet visionen
zu haben die andere vielleicht noch
nichts sehen und rückschläge immer
wieder auch als chance zu begreifen
die wenigsten forscherinnen und forscher
erfahren die aufmerksamkeit die amt die
anerkennung die ihnen zusteht und viel
zu oft findet ihre arbeit im verborgenen
statt und viel zu oft ist unklar ob ihre
ideen überhaupt zur umsetzung kommen und
erlauben sie mir diesen einschub in der
forschung ist es da wie in der politik
es reicht nicht gute ideen zu haben und
diese aufzuschreiben
sie müssen umgesetzt werden und darauf
kommt es an und das haben wir die
nächsten vier jahre vor
aber
zur forschung
forderungen forscher brauchen also viel
durchhaltevermögen viel motivation und
mut gerade jetzt wo viele
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
vielleicht sogar mehr denn je
kritik am verein dungen und sogar
drohungen erfahren das verdient unseren
respekt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ohne mut
gibt es keinen fortschritt und keinen
aufbruch das sind beides begriffe die
heute mehr als nur einmal gefallen sind
und das nicht ohne guten grund
fortschritt und aufbruch das ist die
überschrift unserer politik der nächsten
vier jahre und fortschritt und aufbruch
ist das land ist das was das land jetzt
auch dringend braucht und deshalb
wollen auch wir nötig seien das haben
sie frau ministerin in ihrer rede auch
noch einmal sehr deutlich gemacht wir
wollen mutige politik machen die den
menschen mut macht und ihnen vor allen
dingen den raum gibt selbst mutig zu
sein und einer dieser räume wird da zu
sein die neue deutsche agentur für
transfer und innovation hier wollen wir
mutige ideen und forschungsergebnisse
schneller in die umsetzung bringen denn
bisher geht viel zu viel potenzial
verloren und was mit sprung innovationen
und sprint angefangen hat führt daten
die breite und vor allem bezieht daten
dabei eine gruppe von
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern die viel zu oft und
viel zu lange bevor übersehen worden
sind die forscherinnen und forschern an
den hochschulen für angewandte
wissenschaften
wir
als spd
wissen seit mehr als 50 jahren um ihre
bedeutung und weekend ihr potenzial über
eine millionen studierende sind an einer
der 246 deutschen hochschulen für
angewandte wissenschaften eingeschrieben
das sind mehr als ein drittel aller
studierenden in deutschland und das sind
über eine million menschen mit ideen mit
talenten und dem wunsch zukunft zu
gestalten und gleichzeitig sind sie
angehende wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler mit einer besonders
starken anwendungsorientierung eine
kompetenz die wir dringend brauchen die
aber noch viel zu wenig gefördert wird
und diese lücke zwischen grundlagen- und
innovationsforschung werden wir
schließen bis zur gründung der daten
bauen wir dafür die bestehenden
förderprogramme deutlich aus
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben lust auf zukunft wir haben mut
zur veränderung und vielleicht ist das
der entscheidende unterschied zu den
vergangenen 16 jahren und mit diesem mut
wagen ihr mehr fortschritt und gestalten
den aufbruch für unser land vielen dank
weitere wortmeldungen zu diesen
themenbereichen liegen nicht vor ich
hoffe auf die zusatzpunkte 1 avis 1 c es
handelte und meine damen und herren habe
ich ihnen schon angekündigt das sind so
genannte überweisungen im vereinfachten
verfahren anträge die hier ohne
aussprache verwiesen werden überwiesen
werden in die zuständigen ausschüsse und
das meine damen und herren können wir
ihnen relativ entspannt sparen ersparen
ebenso wie die wahl der vertreter der
bundesrepublik in der in die
parlamentarische versammlung des
europarats und
weitere wahlen beispielsweise zu
migrieren jungen gemäß § 3 des bundes
schulden wesen gesetzes sie merken schon
das ist wichtig aber durchaus sperrig
und deswegen werden wir die gelegenheit
nutzen bevor es hier im plenum
weitergeht in gut 20 25 minuten mit
dieser offenen aussprache zur politik
der neuen bundesregierung da wird ihr
kurator karl lauterbach der
bundesgesundheitsminister übrigens ans
pult gehen wie gesagt bis dahin
verlassen wir vorübergehend das plenum
verlassen vorübergehend auch berlin und
liefern ihnen tagesaktuelle dinge von
anderen nicht ganz unwesentlichen
schauplätzen der welt nach und melden
uns dann rechtzeitig wieder zurück hier
aus dem deutschen bundestag aber 1 2 1
gp japan ina baltes